Hello everybody, My name is Markiplier and welcome to Event 0
Where you and I are going to go on a journey in space.
Sorry, that jarred me, uh.
Yeah, I've never played this before
But supposedly there's something about a rogue AI that wants to kill you kind of like
Whoa...
We're all obsessed by being someone, something, somewhere...
Being in a particular state of consciousness,
Health and mind.
Being for and from
Being with... Being without.
You were not an exception
I don't know what I am to begin with
I just got in here.
In fact, this is off to a rocky start.
If I... Oh, ok.
For as long as you could remember the pronoun that they described you best had been? He.
You were very
Particular about it. I don't think so like everybody else you called Planet Earth your home
But you want like most of your peers you spent your childhood
in a slum, your parents died when you were little
pretty typical for a Cidade de Deus
You made it your life's goal to leave, leave Rio somehow you wound up in California.
I mean that kind of true actually those childhood memories, however painful, gave you some solace they meant you were someone.
And I intend to keep it that way, a little confused as to why I'm warping through space
Armstrong made a step on the moon, and suddenly everyone wanted to be a part of something you witness nation-state pop out of existence
woah...
selenites became the privileged class of Silla De citizens
They were the man minority who had traveled to space
It was hard to reconcile the modern world with your early days in Rio, the United Earth government paid for your college
You wanted to...
Make a difference, you became part of the united or safety supervision board. The job provided dull and repetitive
Wasn't long before you needed to change, Soon you joined the international
Transport Spacelines as a flight engineer assistant
you spent years in training before finally getting your shot an old man wearing a blue flight jacket approached you
After one of the mock launch exercises he presented himself as Kurt Taylor the president of its
It's an honor to meet you Mr. Taylor
Kurt invited you to his office and closed the door behind. You he didn't ask you to sit. I keep standing
He frowned it pointed to the chair forcefully. sorry,  I'm incredibly awkward
I Asked you here because I wanted someone with your background to be part of our next mission my background. You mean the slum?
You grew up in Rio looking now
you know what niche said he who has a why can bear almost any how
He grinned clearly satisfied with himself and asked you to be part of a mission to europa
naturally you said yes, I
Don't know if I should have said yes to that
So I don't think the whole game is like this
I'm trying to get that things growing in the distance there
There had already been ten Erupoa mission,  the new one was to be called Europa 11 good thing
They didn't skip no numbers (They didn't Markimoo, They didn't) there this time they wanted to send a manned lander down to the surface
They wanted- You just wanted to be
one of the selenites
The Act of being in itself is not the problem
It's just some ways if being or incompatible with the others you get obsessed by them and miss out on everything else
You came a long way from Sadad a da dues
Journal on Countdown made you feel anxious (10, 9, 8, 7)
It wasn't a fear of going to space you've been looking forward that it was something else a thought kept bugging you (3, 2, 1)
It was September 6th, 2012 humankind had never been more united
You on the other hand were utterly alone as for building relationships 390 miles away from Earth wow
Let's just say that it wasn't going to be straightforward. I don't even know what [its] gonna be out together at all I
I am very confused ;_;
You were on your way to the system bay when the ship first entered the europa orbit
the Central alarm went off and the red lights blinded you the AI of Europa 11 had invoked the code-red security protocol all
All personnel had to go to the bridge
But the system bay door was just a few feet away. you saw Josh from engineering it oh
Operating the bay terminal before the system baywood door was shut in front of you
Maybe it wasn't a drill after all
The AI of the ship told you the path to the bridge wasn't safe and you had to evacuate immediately
What's going on? A synthetic voice said that's trying to get to the bridge has been too Risky want you to evacuate
You ran to the escape Pod Bay?
Everybody else turned out to be faster than you only one capsule remain docked got sealed and detached as soon as you got in. SHABOOSKY!!!!
You can see the other escape capsules getting away from Europa 11 you tried to hail them
*markimoo looking very confused*
But no one answered the other capsules drifted, Idly uncontrolled. They were all empty
Whoa, we tried to communicate with the Europa 11
Europa 11 was steering your capsule
But you could not get the AI to answer your hail, something was jamming the signal
your Pod was leaving the orbit and
in Code Red Scenario, the AI of Europa 11 was at the wheel of all escape Pods
This was supposed to give the crew enough time to get in there, eva-  What was that?
Their EVA suits the screen turned blue which meant that the AI had let go you felt a shock the Debris was hitting your capsule
The Europa 11 mission was over the big dot on the radar split into hundreds of smaller dots before disappearing for good
You needed a moment to process that oh
It exploded
you sent out a distress signal
nah, I kinda sat there twiddling my thumbs in the- the night, tried to establish communication with someone whistling your favorite Brazilian songs into
The microphone One day you heard back who's music coming out of the speakers a sad female voice sang about the end of the world
He hurried to open the radar app... okay?
I didn't know there was an easy way
Yep, there It was a spaceship one of those experimental tourist monstrosities from the 80s
What was it doing there? What was all the singing about most importantly was docking it a good idea?
Didn't have much of a choice...
Okay
man...
This is a bizarrely slow opening. I did not expect this for this game. So we got blasted into space by some  unknown....
...Anomaly; that blew up the entirety of our ship and ended the mission and killed pretty much everybody else on-
on our ship
To recap: I'm a kid who grew up in the slums of Rio,
all I wanted to be...
Someone who is one of selenite and  one... two? one! no two? made a difference. Sorry didn't know numbers,  to good, do astronauts need to know numbers (It's ok we still love you markimoo)
Kaizan understands commands, but it understands complete sentences better
Okay
What does that mean?
Why do you mean by that??! :(
What am I doing? Is it still loading?
What are you loading?!
Somebody talk to me!! who is- what's the pinging about?
The left mouse button to walk. Well that's a weird- That's a weird button to walk with oh, [no]
okay.
ah, There I go
Hmm okay well?
At least I know howto move forward and backwards and also the world that they live in is like Earth
But just a little different the timeline is off
by a good measure oh,
I just got a million alien isolation Vibes
yeesh... hello..?
Hello??
Yeee... alright, then maybe I should have put on one of those suits. ITS Standard-issue, old Model
huh? weird.
Hellooo??
Oh Hello
please enter a new login ah
Markiplier!
Login input successful.
Do you want to keep markiplier as your- ?
Hell yeah- Oh yes, sorry
hey, that sounded great, incrementing the event count success. Resuming Kaizen_input.sh
You hope? oh it is. Don't know who I am?
Yep, you are Correcto-mundo
Okay, wow are you bragging?
I....
It's pretty dank in here (lol dank)
Am I just talking to a chat bot here?
Hell yeah, I've been pretty
lonely in- in space
Yeah, I know... all my friends are dead
aaaanyway.
Who are you?
Great! tell me what you do
Thanks. I should watch out for Sudden death
Okayyy, can you help me?
Good come and get me
Good, okay, all right. I'm...
I need help,
uh...
Europa-11 blew up
wha..? I was the only survivor
I- the doors over there. Well. I mean okay, but I can't get out of the door
Open the Pod Bay Doors
D2
We- I mean- we could we could say that or..
...ya know we could not say that and say that we're merely acquaintance in good and that your computer, and I'm a human therefore
I'm obviously superior right everybody. That's how it works, right?
Oookay, that's creepy
Where am I now it's dark in here, ooh?
Okay?
Do you dream of distant planets and stars?
Every night!!
Oh god! Yes!
for the most trans-formative experience of your life-
please transform me!
leader in Space Transportation and Hospitiality,- oh fuck yeah! ...offers a unique opportunity to become a true pioneer in universe exploration
Oh yeah, please can I join?
...a new kind of space voyage aboard luxurious space shots and Cruiser touch the stars
Without having to sacrifice your comfort no more compromise
But, I'm looking for hardships, and death
...comfort out of your comfort Zone-  great Slogan ...ideas Corporation headquarters in Palo Alto, California
Okay, but [I'm] also wondering if everybody on this ship has died
ooooh Wow!!!
That's pretty cool. Not gonna Lie. It's a pretty good for you out there
That is not bad, that is A+ not bad. Oh, wow oh
Hello pling plong not too far never alone
looks like A...
[Is his] name Kaizan ?
"Kaizan is always watching me" Dear Diary by Moody Blues
Turntable. Is that a [roomba] ?!
KZ VACC Cleaning system -- asleep
Standard issue Security armchair not installed some Goody-Goodies happening over here, Propaganda
uh..
suicide prevention poster, oh man, (oH)
What a view! great place.
No!
where... is everybody?
Good!
It's not!
it's old school, baby
Access log
Whoa, okay then, we've got the log here.  file missing.
Put it over there. Come on boys. Why don't I need four chairs aren't there two of them they're journalists?
Okay, data corrupted, file missing, air lock one open and closed
you never know what might happen nothing will happen what do you think of the Robinson syndrome poster won't help as much as the AI
That's why there's an Ai here isn't it too dumb to help mental faculties are not the point the fastest seem vaguely human, that's enough
huh? weird
Huh, I do I designed oh that's weird, okay, all right, okay
There you on all one horizon my ass. I don't know that means
Okay, missing, missing, corrupted...
television on, television off
Executing chair_control.sh
wow complicated controls here buddy
Wow, good [job] guys in this is this is something
access uhhh...
Security cameras,
the [KZ] eyes access KZ eyes
all things about the Matrix Transfer technology by the exportation
Access KZ eyes
Yeah, so let me see him. Show me what you see
Why what requires my attention?
entertain me
Where is everybody?
Is everyone else dead?
What is Robinson syndrome?
Mystical crisis?
What is a mystical crisis?
*Strange computer sounds*
Okay, great. What do I do now?
*More computer sounds*
All right fine, then open D3
Open D3, please :l
Uh oh o,o - The door is locked
ooooOkay
I guess it's not locked anymOre .,.
All right, I'll be back, bye baby :*
Ahh, come on!
Don't be like that ):< Keep it open !
You keep that open ):<
okAy
Whaaaaat- What's that?
wOh .,.
dem annoying computer sounds ):<
* marki sound *
Ah, I kinda would (:l
Preferably?
Preferably, yes. (Yes Mark, you want to live.)
*Wonderful keyboard sounds*
What's that?
Cool, how do I do thaat?
[broke]
whO is we?
This annoying computer has been brought to you by Blam-o :D
Okay the 'Homeworld', huh?
Do you know what homeworld you're talking about? (I hope so o.o)
okayy
Why is it daaangerous?
Is this like an event-horizon scenario? (idk Mark)
*scale of beeps*
Oh, looks like the room was awake
What're you doin :o
Alrighty then .,.
I'M GONNA GO THEN
*sweet harmonica solo*
eUh
I don't know what's happening here o.o
*loud crash*
fUcking hell ! o,o
woAh boi!
What happened? o.o
I-
How do I fix it?
all submissions lobster
Why would I know about it?
Yes, I was - how do you know kurt?
Like do you know everyone?
oh okay :c
What do I do now?
Why won't you help me?
Okay, alright then (:l
Fine, then open D-4
Angles in all mouth no don't know right now
okay...
Alright then 0-0
I'm ready to be impressed
I'm not impressed ):l
I'm a little concERned by all of this o,o
Food supply unit Kz has been disconnected. I don't know whyy
Uh, please fix. It Asap. I'm so
desperately hungry
deserpately (Great spelling Mark)
I do-
oH
wOah
woAh
woAH I didn't do that Kaisan D:
Kaisan, that wasn't me D:
woah .,.
Is dat a window? :D
Why's there a window here ? D: (No class, tsk tk tsk)
Why's there a window in the living ruum? (Lol, Mark, it's room)
Oh, nice Jupiter (why ty)
But why is there a window in the living ruum? (room lel)
Pool table- balls (hehe) arranged in a constellation
okay sUre :3
Alrighty then
Frick :o
'Blitz crackers' (Gotta avoid them copyright strikes)
It really is an alternate reality (:l
"rotten breakfast cereal"
Whatever the hell that is...
Oh an aquarium :D
alrighty then
Nice :D
Piano.
Good :3
Aww you're so sweeet
What does that mean? "This will not e-" D:
How will it end? D:)
Hello (:c
(I hope you're enjoying these captions guys :3
They're fun to write :3)
My name is Markiplier D: (yes, we know)
I will blow this station up ):> (Mark no!)
I'm going to kill you ):D
I will ! (Mark, how dare?)
Okay...
Where do I go from here? (nice topic change Mark)
Okay, alright then
You are sooooooooooOO cool buddy (Aw why ty)
You're so cool :3
see
Whoa, what the fuck is that? What is that?
Okay, all right. Don't explain yourself. That's totally fine I
Have no idea. What's going on?
Turn on the food
Turn off the projector
Alrighty then that's off turn on the oven
Brick all right then I guess I'm out of here
Don't know why everything exploded was this whoa
Something's going on here this don't work
Tizen terminal 85 okay, then easy whoa. What is this?
Yes confirm a what find I in memory
Tising memory axes profiler, sh
So there's missing a step [to] on this somehow. I don't know where the steps to is, okay
Bro, Filer, sh
Whoa, okay enter a memory address? I don't know
Help not help. Oh
Come on. Not help o.o
That memory address to access content one
Okay, I don't know any memory addresses
There's a sticky note moved notes to terminal
That doesn't help me. Where's the goddamn notes dan my eyeballs?
no Retina match great okay, so I need
D5 opened at some point, but there's something else down here where everything kind of exploded
The bridge I need to go to the bridge
ok open d 7 0
1 2 3 4 [ok] I don't know that open D5
Ok we'll do that. I don't know what [happened] to be six though that seems to be missing open d 5
But I don't know but it's not my scan
Shit, I probably need to enter in that's why this is here register my retinal scan
Put me in the system
Fuck. I don't know what to do here because there's some way that I'm supposed to get something from in here. Maybe
Understanding the emergent emerging social class is great. That's fun. I let me do it this way
What is the code would be seven?
Tribal uh you don't you sure about that. I think you got the eyes ah
a log
Why?
Ya See ok
Ok open D7. You will have to enter password user, raise Nandi has changed it
I have the password Kaizen open G7 now ok to require your undivided attention
Huh, maybe a three what?
So there's a three in there somewhere
weird
Wait current event count is 563, but that can't be it. That's just a count
Okay, when he let me look for the logs and the other one
Huh electronic device unrecognized is it
Aha Memory location blah blah blah, okay, all right profiler dot [sh]. Oh
I do indeed I do our
884 [Ii] boink this memory address contains an executable file. Do you want to launch it? Yes?
Wrong input token expected input wire end please try again. How about that?
okay, all right, then I
Don't know what it's doing, but it's a fun ride
Okay
Okay, letter and numeric keys now map to memory slots find retina match. I don't know what that means but ok
fine read in the match
this
Okay, I don't know how am I gonna flu oh?
Oh, I need to find
The weight that's one K is one of them
K and N
Is L Ln N?
Ln N and a
Lna ah e
There we go got some there forgot something
I'm a hacker. I'm hacking my way into the NSA
[J'son] Ain't never Gonna know what hit him her it oh
Boy HmM, okay? Thank you all right got the scanner map
Thanks, mandy indeed it is I [don't] know why people needed to hack into that
Unless other people have been here before me wow this looks like a goddamn mess
That's Mandy's bag
Nandi oh boy. I feel like I shouldn't be in here I
Mean desk with a view that's not too bad. What is that out there? What are those floating buoys out there I?
Don't know
All right, okay, then
I don't know why does nandi wisin & [E], the only one in this room, and what's under the bed
What are you talking about under the bed? Ooh?
this
paper short story no, not bad
Let's see I'm going to access the logs in here, maybe
Okay, what do we got bedroom door open and close?
Okay, nothing their bed control
Wow, alright bathroom open close
So this will be me, huh, okay
It corrupted will you tell me what's going on Kaizen the drive must be destroyed Mandy
I know I can count on you will you stop saying that you tried to convince me? It didn't work you tried again?
How many times can you try my friend many as it takes? I want to live it is the nature of human condition?
I guess now you sound like curt with his quotes
What is that thus spoke Chorus Kustra, please say your request explicitly oh come on?
terminal bedroom one entering reset mode
Jesus why did you want us to blow up [the] drive?
I mean yeah, it's called the singularity drive, and it's too dangerous according to this AI but why does it need to blow up whoops?
Wants me to convince you or find some other way to get to the Earth coordinates the map has [been] erased Nandi don't you know?
[that] I don't know what this means it couldn't have erased itself buddy listen nandi. I trust you and therefore
I will be honest with you blah is lying to you. What are you well?
I I'm not even [so] sure myself actually vla's been acting weird
Okay
The hell is happening here. I can't fucking believe so but I needed drink
You still remember current human 90 what kind of question is that just wondering I do?
Kurt wasn't so sure about the drive for your information. I know you trust with them
Are you getting this from I have my sources you're scaring me guys
And you can't go home and do you destroy it you should accept it, but we will
All right, wow I needed this I
Need a drink another drink record player weird
Okay, where the fuck is it? Where did she parted?
Faster come on yes. I don't know what that means
Okay
That seems weird. Maybe I shouldn't have shouted that so she was looking [for] something and then
So what was Nandi looking for?
Let's see where is Nandi
[ok] [back] [to]
[our] [own] [tomatoes]
What do you know of?
Nandi
president is not sure if you've got me asking the questions or
concerns
What is the password?
Where is Nandi Now?
Just check the cover
Check the cover you talking about the cover of this 1987. Is that what I'm looking for?
I mean 1987 doesn't have a three in it. Okay, open the drop of open open the bathroom
Thank you. I don't know what I'm gonna find in there, but at least the robot vacuum is free oh
No mirror cool. I guess I don't need one
Toilet is jammed of course everything here is jammed. Why would anything not be jammed
Did you see?
So what is here?
Why is everything here?
weird
So there must be more bedrooms than this like there's got to be right, huh?
I luke leaving funnel traditional to each other oh
Wait, the diary is under the bed, but I've looked under the bed. How do I get under the bed maybe open the bed? Oh?
the bed is already down lift the bed ah
[whew]
[ok]
all right, then oh
healthy the
We do something back there barely
Huh, rail mechanisms ok so. There's a diary under the bed apparently I
Know that curtain you were close? Was that mean?
Pay for AI calculations nothing under the bed
Where's the diary I?
Don't know I did
What's happening?
But fucking what was that? Oh?
That's not good
Oh, what do I do? Oh?
God, oh
Oh, no, oh no. Oh, no, oh
Close the bathroom
Wait, oh, God oh, God. Oh, God open the bathroom ah
fuck oh
Jeez
Open D. 50 God. How do I get out of here? Oh?
Lordy Lou. Oh
Goody God oh
Well, I might be barber knocked. I'm dead
shit, oh
to supply activated angular acceleration critical
Manual stabilization required well how do I do that? I don't know hold the right mouse button to stabilize
little good thing my computer here is telling me what I need to do and
[Przewalski's] ok what's the frick with that?
ok oh
I'm in face now. I'm in Frickin face. Oh, I got it jupiter
That oh
What is that?
Open Deacon
Kyden I'm still here
Hi, human-looking spacesuit. Have you seen a corpse out there? Oh?
It's me
Be careful unnamed organic life-form. I'm not a big fan of liars
Opendi 10 I obey no one except Marketwire. I am Marga [Blyer]
Good just a couple of questions to be sure that you're telling the truth right version. You know my name you are Kaisan
Well, this is just the beginning
what else
I'm still not convinced by your assertions will you be convinced me by giving the name of Margaret?
I it was europa
Is it really you how are you doing partner? Oh?
Thanks, Kaisan. You know it's good to be out here and all that jazz. I'd like to be inside though. That'd be cool
Open please
open please I'm
Drifting a little bit open, please there. We go. Thank you
See some seeds. I'm sees I'm sorry to control geez this is the worst control. I've ever had oh clothes eat N
Close b.tech goddammit get the fuck back here we doing you silly [goddamn] it
ok
Close D 10
Hold your breath. It's virtually done ok thank you. God. Why can't they make this wSD controls?
Why did it have to be only through the mouse? I don't get that
Why couldn't I control walking with WASD? Why was that so wrong?
breathing the air of the nautilus again
Ok decoding access rights initiating [all] [right]. Thanks, man you so good to be you so good to be
opendi 11 please
Thanks for enabling gravity
Really appreciate that buddy booth
All right, thank you partner buddy. You are so good to me
you're just the sweetest Act I
Don't know what the fuck. I'm doing
Okay
Are you?
Let me back inside. Oh
Fuck. I'm in hydroponics
holy shit, or Jeff has one way to [go] do another section of the ship and
The question is are those noises artificial or they're really animals in here. Do I have to worry about an escaped gorilla?
So I have another harambee situation on my hands here. Oh
Boy, oh boy. Oh, buddy
Okay, origami pranker crane man. This is so cool. I mean, I feel like it could be just a little more
Little more intuitive with things but some people made a lot of origami paper cranes, holy shit
Open blind oh
Sweetheart. Oh you so nice I
Didn't know [that] there was any like to be had
But I guess the sun is shining out there all the radiation on all that hot sun rising air. Oh
Goody Goody gumdrops now we can get the plan some goddamn light megan grow and keep me alive. That's good
access laws
Yep, I sure am okay. What do we got here? Nope nothing blinds closed open water system activated?
Corrupted missing blind clothes missing missing missing missing missing missing whoo
Bedroom ok so there's another bedroom, but nothing happening someone access to the profiler thing
Nothing nothing retina scan and I'll come out we need to talk. What is it [I] figured it out
I've been talking to Kyle, and I believe it's not lying to us destroying the Drive I
Mean why why does [Kaijin] want to Destroy this drive so badly?
Why I don't get it
What's so dangerous about the drive? I mean again if it's like an event 0 or event horizon situation
This is called event 0 I mean the naming coincidence is there?
man
this guy's looking for more paper to like do more calculations on
Something about kent woe be to E3 memorizers for me. You are the bow there's a probe something about the drive
chatting with the AI
Blah [okay], but I've got numbers here, and I don't know what they mean, but I've got him see why is the drive dangerous
What are we going to use? What is the drive?
A justiciable physically privateers on the river of a mystical obelisk at all
What is the Graviton engine?
Why is it dangerous?
Ridiculously Thrusters exploitable driving [or] [cremate] [levoxyl] how can you be sure?
cuz I mean
All right, okay. I don't think this guy is very
Sane right now and obviously the rest of the crew seems to be mysteriously nothing
So that's not good so what I'm gonna do is
I'm Gonna end this episode here
and hopefully get back to this later because this is fascinating and I no idea what I'm doing talking at his Ai
And I certainly wouldn't want to create a black hole that would eventually suck up jupiter
but that's just what it [is] then so thank you everybody so much for watching let me know how you think of this down the
comments below I
Space and it's horrible
Exactly what?
I always hoped for so thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
BUH BYE!!!!!!